[Music]
in democracies the government does not
provide its own news content for the
media to broadcast that my friends is
not news it is propaganda in democracies
the government does not or should not
cherry-pick amongst the news media to
allow access or interviews only to those
who they like I'm puzzled the actions of
this government did not sit easily with
its top man a former career journalist
and editor of full medieval Talent the
executive has already taken back control
of the lobby briefing for Westminster
journalists by demanding it takes place
in Downing Street then on Monday only
those on an approved list who actually
allowed into number 10 to hear expert
briefing the rest were told to skedaddle
which led to a walk out of the entire
lobby corps in solidarity I applaud
those journalists at stake is the very
freedom of the press to hold the
government to account without fear or
favor the freedom that underpins all our
democratic institutions I urge the
executive to chill out turn the page and
open itself up to wider scrutiny once
more it's playing with fire if it
persists in control-freak we with the
press and many more will end up hacked
off in the news your brothers cool I
have no idea I very much doubt it you
know him as well as I do not his style
at all I mean his style I would I have
said to him which is there is no point
in picking a fight with the press when
they're all on your essentially on your
side and what breaks it to work see
here's the thing normally when I hear
journalists and people moan I think I'll
just give it a break on this one
actually I'm with you and I think the
support the way that everybody so those
who were selected decided up with us we
will not put and if they're going we're
going to it was a rare moment actually
when the press and the media actually
caved in a gentlemanly or decent fashion
so I have to say I agree with you I hope
they can reconsider it
this is sounds very quick it's not the
British Way I agree and it's so
important I think we should hear from
the shadow culture secretary Tracy
Braben who made a statement to the
Commons on this subject post brexit
trade plans is an issue of great public
concern and access to a high-level
briefing should not be handpicked by
government political advisors the
exclusion of some publications led to
every major national broadcaster and
newspaper walking out Lobby journalists
access to government is vital for a
functioning and healthy democracy and
this latest deterioration in relations
between the government of the lobby is
deeply concerning very strong passionate
words from Tracy Braden and I think we
will be may be discussing her attire a
bit later in the program Greg what do
you think no it doesn't end with a lobby
I mean this is happening they won't let
certain politicians go on certain shows
they won't that hard time I just seems
to me I think it's a very unwise thing
to do this government thinks it's
all-powerful it's had a big got a big
majority thinks everyone loves them you
can turn that can turn very quickly and
you know when the Daily Mail starts
writing you know leaders against what
you're doing in terms of democracy which
is what they did the big conservatives
should be very careful I agree and when
they start wanting to amplify their
message the press won't be one side to
do Alex
I mean does this sign to you like an
inside bubble story that doesn't concern
Jay public well actually I think it does
concern Joe public what we don't want to
see is the start of or the loss of
freedom of speech you know the loss of
the ability to you know really hear from
all perspectives about what's really
going on you know as a young person I do
actually use social media a lot and I've
got interesting stat here in 2019 49
percent of people use social media for
news and in fact Facebook was the third
most popular source of news in in the UK
so that's behind BBC and and and ITV
Michelle I mean we've seen
Downing Street used social media as an
alternative for mainstream media quite
quite a lot and do you think this is
just the way things are going I think
you mentioned them using social media
let's have a little look at our Prime
Minister communicating directly with
people hi folks so welcome to another
edition of people's PM views your chance
to put your questions to me and I want
to answer as many questions as I can I I
want you to know that I will be saying
more about leaving the EU I will be
giving an address to the nation at 10
p.m. on Friday here on my Facebook page
so thanks all all of you for tuning in
the Prime Minister and his appealing
directly for people to get in direct
contact with him so they can go through
the questions and respond directly and
what these what the government is
tapping into is there is a significant
loss of trust at the moment in the media
there are a lot of people who now don't
believe rightly or wrongly he's kind of
irrelevant but they don't believe what
they're seeing and hearing they feel
like they're that they are being fed
propaganda by the media to further the
media's
objectives so I think that this
government has recognized that is
tapping into that selective briefing he
can go but you publications I think the
mirror HuffPost the eye I think it's an
incredibly slippery slope when you start
going to I don't think it's I don't
think it's right but I do think also
that there is almost a sense of
entitlement now that these media outlets
have are a lot of them have which is
you're gonna be on my show and you're
gonna debate me end of and we're going
to humiliate you they choose all the
time whether they going to come but
there's nothing wrong with Boris Johnson
trying to talk to the public
I used to be Bella Furness when he made
that address you know that LBC took at
Sky News to it you know the BBC ITV
refused to play that out do you agree
with that because it was shot by the
Prime Minister's I said in my queue that
is propaganda you're allowing Downing
Street to create and curate and national
importance we leave the EU after seven
years we leave the EU after 47 years and
it's reduced to a clip on the number
there is a principle and I think it's a
very democratic principle in Westminster
that all journalists didn't matter which
TV station you're from radio website
newspaper left-right Sun mirror mail
times doesn't matter you have access to
public information you get that
information and then you give it to the
public what they're trying to do now is
restrict who gets the information I
think it's a very dangerous path to go
down they want journalists to become
clients a favored few who that will
allow in will then worry about their
access and will they then challenge the
ministers or the officials who are
giving them that information
it's I can see why it's happening
because they're drunk on power the media
and the public will turn against them so
do you honestly think so you've got a
Tory government that's pro-business
lower tax etc you honestly think that
those publications that are earned by
very wealthy people will suddenly just
be playing devil's advocate switch from
supporting them through to McDowell
email already has through to support
democracy just about the video when the
Prime Minister recorded do you think
that should have been played by all the
major broadcasters do you have issues I
mean I think that any content that's
created like that you know everyone
should be able to have access I think
what worries me looking at this whole
picture is that I'm going to look at the
US you have the government Trump having
control of the medium what goes out
where then
he's sound boxing his own things on his
Twitter accounts too many millions of
people let's be honest is a huge reach
to love his contents of these got
ultimate control I think that's what I
wouldn't want to have happen where
social media is i outlet of what I want
to say but nothing else can be
interpreted conservative saying this is
Chloe Smith the briefing was additional
to normal Lobby handlings those Lobby
handling is an entirely normal standard
in routine and have been so over
successive governments in addition to
the briefings and the very normal
routine operation of the lobby the Prime
Minister has a huge amount of further
appointments and engagements on a range
of channels and move on I don't need a
few people in the world who can tell me
what they think of my outfit senior
Susanna then I I don't want to know so
it's safe to say if people need to
started commentating on what I was
wearing I would when she did to wear an
outfit in Parliament that revealed wait
for it her bare shoulder that's right
the internet went into absolute meltdown
after one user tweeted a photo of Tracy
saying the person said is this really
appropriate attire for Parliament but
Tracy was quick to hit back at trolls
with the perfect response she said sorry
I don't have time to reply to all of you
commenting on this but I can confirm
that I'm not a slag hung over at art
about to breastfeed a slapper drunk just
being banged over a wheelie bin who knew
people could get so emotional over the
shoulder
well said Tracy and forgiving those
keyboard warriors the ultimate cold
shoulders you know our straight talker
of the week if I keel over and have a
heart attack near to the doctor's
hospital I do not expect him to come and
treat me wearing sandals and flip-flops
and a small top you have a certain
stress sense if you're an MP if you're a
surgeon if you're a doctor if you're a
politician if you're a lawyers a fact
I must say you know I'll never be as
judgmental as those idiots on Twitter
are however do you think that certain
workplaces have certain dress codes and
I think in Parliament and in business
environments most of there's
professional dress down and over time
they change and they change quite
dramatically there was a time not until
quite recently you had to wear a tie in
Parliament I actually think I'm
understand what she's saying when she's
wearing to be honest found completely
honest about it that's why I'm gonna be
completely honest about if that was my
daughter I mean my mum would have said
to me darling put a jacket on having
said that she was fearless and
provocative say to somebody are you sure
you want to wear that you sure where
where was her bra well I'll have to
think about what I'm gonna wear next
weekend that's all we've got time for
this week but you can join in the debate
by searching for the pledge on Twitter
and on the sky news Facebook page if you
want to take a little break will you you
can listen to us on Apple podcasts
Spotify er whichever lap you prefer
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time